This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. During the Cold War, a so-called Iron Curtain separated eastern and western Europe, communism from capitalism, the Soviet Union from everyone else. In some places, it was an actual wall, like in Berlin, and in other places, it was just a bar-pwire fence. This border was long, stretching from northern Finland through Central Europe. It covered 12,500 kilometers, or almost 8,000 miles. This mortar was long, stretching from northern Finland through Central Europe. It covered 12 and a half thousand kilometers, or almost 8,000 miles. And all along this 8,000 mile border, there was a nomance land, couple hundred yards across,
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在冷战期间，所谓的“铁幕”将东西欧分隔开来，将共产主义与资本主义分隔开来，将苏联与世界其他地方分隔开来。在某些地方，它是一堵真正的墙，就像在柏林那样；而在另一些地方，它只是一道带刺的铁丝网。这条边界很长，从芬兰北部一直延伸到中欧。它全长1.25万公里，也就是将近8000英里。这条边界很长，从芬兰北部一直延伸到中欧。它全长12500公里，也就是将近8000英里。在这长达8000英里的边界沿线，有一片宽达几百码的无人区，
where there was almost no human activity. When the Cold War ended and the walls and fences came down, people noticed something interesting. That's reporter Emmett Fitzgerald. This neglected strip of land had become a productive ecosystem. With forests and fields, it was a haven, particularly for migratory birds. Soon after the Berlin Wall fell, conservationists from East and West came together to protect this accidental refuge
那里几乎没有人类活动。当冷战结束，墙壁和栅栏倒塌时，人们注意到了一些有趣的事情。这是记者埃米特·菲茨杰拉德。这片被忽视的狭长地带已经变成了一个高产的生态系统。这里有森林和田野，是一片避难所，尤其是对候鸟而言。柏林墙倒塌后不久，东西方的环保主义者走到了一起，共同保护这个意外的避难所，
for birds and animals. Because the No Man's land was so long, they realized that it could link habitats West and West came together to protect this accidental refuge for birds and animals. Because the No Man's land was so long, they realized that it could link habitats throughout Central Europe. Today, the so-called European Green Belt traces the path of the old iron curtain. It connects national parks and nature preserves and helps animals move around in a landscape dominated by humans. It's what's known as a wildlife corridor.
为鸟类和动物提供庇护。由于这片无人区如此漫长，他们意识到它可以连接整个中欧的栖息地。今天，所谓的“欧洲绿带”沿袭了旧铁幕的路线。它连接着国家公园和自然保护区，帮助动物在人类主导的景观中四处活动。这就是所谓的野生动物走廊。
Wildlife corridors can link to extremely large habitats like two national parks or two national forks or a national forest in a national park, say across a very large freeway, or it can link relatively small fragments of habitats and within very developed metropolitan areas. That's Louise Mazingo. She's chair of the Department of Landscape Architecture
野生动物走廊可以连接极其广阔的栖息地，比如两个国家公园，或者两个国家公园，或者国家公园里的国家森林，比方说跨越一条非常宽的高速公路；它也可以连接相对较小的栖息地碎片，并且是在高度开发的都市区之内。这是路易丝·马辛戈。她是加州大学伯克利分校景观建筑
and Environmental Planning at the University of California Berkeley. And she says that a wildlife corridor doesn't have to be a massive greenway through Europe. It could be as simple as a concrete pipe or a small, kind of vegetated ditch under a freeway. Wildlife corridors might be the most critical in urban areas, free pipe or a small, kind of vegetated ditch under freeway. Wildlife corridors might be the most critical
与环境规划系的主任。她说，野生动物走廊不一定非得是贯穿欧洲的大型绿道。它可能很简单，只是一根混凝土管，或者是高速公路下一条长满植物的小水沟。野生动物走廊可能是最至关重要的
in urban areas, because sprawling cities and highways have fragmented a lot of wildlife habitat and have forced animals into isolated pockets, which is a problem because animals need to move around in order to find different food sources and mates. In Southern California and abandoned highway underpass began to link two important pieces of habitat in an otherwise industrial area. And what they found is that both of these habitat zones actually were able to support much larger
在城市地区，因为不断扩张的城市和高速公路已经将许多野生动物的栖息地碎片化，并迫使动物进入孤立的狭小区域，这是一个问题，因为动物需要四处移动来寻找不同的食物来源和配偶。在南加州，一个废弃的高速公路地下通道开始将两个重要的栖息地连接起来，而这两个栖息地原本处于工业区之中。他们发现，这两个栖息地实际上都能够支持大得多的
populations unexpected because this relatively small concrete underpass was able to connect the two habitat ranges. And so you had even very large predator species like mountain lines being able to be supported by these fragments of habitat in a very urbanized situation. Today, the abandoned underpass is purposefully protected and maintained as a wildlife corridor. But wildlife corridors don't technically have to be corridors. and underpass is purposefully protected and maintained as a wildlife corridor.
超出预期的种群数量，因为这个相对较小的混凝土地下通道能够将这两个栖息地范围连接起来。因此，甚至连美洲狮这样的大型掠夺性物种，也能在高度城市化的环境中依靠这些零星的栖息地生存下来。如今，这个废弃的地下通道被刻意保护和维护，作为野生动物走廊使用。但严格来说，野生动物走廊不一定非得是走廊。
But wildlife corridors don't technically have to be corridors. They can be any piece of design that facilitates the safe passage of animals through the human built environment from one piece of habitat to another. And they're not always a product of accident and neglect. Sometimes they're very intentional and carefully designed. One of the oldest examples of humans designing a passageway for animals is the fish ladder,
但严格来说，野生动物走廊不一定非得是走廊。它们可以是任何能够便利动物安全穿过人类建设环境、从一个栖息地前往另一个栖息地的设计。而且它们并不总是意外和忽视的产物。有时它们是非常刻意且经过精心设计的。人类为动物设计通道的最古老例子之一就是鱼梯，
which helps migratory species of salmon and steelhead trout get over dams that block their annual migrations upriver to spawn. First patented by a Canadian lumber mill owner in 1837, the standard fish ladder is a series of terrorist pools, with just enough space between them to allow a fish to leap from one pool to the next, slowly climbing the ladder to the other side of the dam. The design takes advantage of Sammon's natural ability to swim upstream through rapids and over small waterfalls. So a quick lesson in salmon migration. Salmon babies hatch in the upper reaches of a river and immediately start making the
它帮助洄游的鲑鱼和硬头鳟越过水坝，这些水坝阻碍了它们每年上游产卵的洄游。标准鱼梯最早于1837年由一位加拿大木材厂老板获得专利，它是一系列阶梯状的水池，水池之间的空间恰到好处，允许鱼从一个水池跃入下一个水池，慢慢爬上鱼梯到达水坝的另一侧。这种设计利用了鲑鱼逆流游过急流和小瀑布的天然能力。下面是关于鲑鱼洄游的快速科普。鲑鱼幼鱼在河流上游孵化，并立即开始向下游游去，
way down the river to the ocean. They hang out at sea for a few years and then, when it's time to mate, miraculously swim their way back up the exact same river to lay their eggs using magnetic fields and smell to navigate. But in the early 20th century, companies started building giant hydroelectric dams on almost every major river in the United States. And they were way too big for a salmon to jump over. And so, at some of these dams, engineers installed fish ladders to help the salmon out.
前往海洋。它们在海里逗留几年，然后，当交配的季节到来时，会奇迹般地逆流而上，沿着完全相同的河流游回原处产卵，依靠磁场和气味来导航。但在20世纪初，各大公司开始在美国几乎每一条主要河流上建造巨大的水力发电大坝。这些大坝对鲑鱼来说实在太高了，根本无法跃过。因此，在其中一些大坝上，工程师们安装了鱼梯来帮助鲑鱼。
And fish ladders have worked well over the years. Part of the problems with fish ladders is that they tend to be very expensive to build. That's Todd Delegon. My name is Todd Delegant. I am the Vice President of Business Development with WUSH Innovations. You'll understand where the name WUSH comes from in a second. Today, there are about 80 to 88,000 barriers in the country
多年来，鱼梯一直发挥着很好的作用。鱼梯的问题之一在于它们的建造成本往往非常高。这是托ッド·德莱甘。我叫托德·德莱甘。我是WUSH创新公司的业务发展副总裁。一会儿你就会明白WUSH这个名字是怎么来的了。今天，国内大约有8万到8.8万处屏障，
that have an elevation of five feet or more. 88,000 dams that fish have to get around. It's a little hard to tell how many actual fish passage installations are at these barriers all around the country, but it is somewhere between 10 and 15%. We estimate. There are a lot of places where a lot of fish
其高度在五英尺或以上。有8.8万座大坝是鱼类必须绕过的。很难说全国这些屏障处究竟有多少实际的鱼类洄游设施，但据我们估计，大概在10%到15%之间。有很多地方，很多鱼
aren't getting anywhere at all because of the barriers that exist. And that's where Todd's company, Woosh, comes in. Fireed into the sky, the salmon of a coming flying fish. I think fish could fly. Think again, I introduce you to the Woosh Fish Cannon. Take a look. For your sweet piece of technology known as the salmon cannon.
因为现有的屏障根本哪儿也去不了。这就是托德的公司WUSH切入的地方。伴随着呼啸声射向天空，鲑鱼变成了会飞的鱼。我以为鱼会飞。再想想吧，我向你隆重介绍WUSH鱼类大炮。看一看。这项被称为鲑鱼大炮的绝妙技术。
You heard them right. The salmon cannon. The salmon cannon actually started out as an apple cannon. The founder of the company, Vince Bryan, owns orchards along the Columbia River in Eastern Washington. And he noticed that the pickers were spending a lot of their time carrying fruit from the tree to storage bins in the center of the orchard.
你没听错。鲑鱼大炮。鲑鱼大炮最初其实是一个苹果大炮。该公司的创始人文斯·布赖恩在华盛顿州东部的哥伦比亚河沿岸拥有果园。他注意到采摘工们花费了大量时间将水果从树上搬运到果园中心的储藏箱里。
It was inefficient. So Vince and Todd built this soft tube, kind of like a fire hose. And inside the tube, they generated a pressure differential, capable of sucking an apple hundreds of feet, and depositing it gently in a storage bin. So they have this effective device for apple picking, but pretty soon they're thinking bigger.
这效率太低了。于是文斯和托德建造了一根软管，有点像消防水带。在软管内部，他们产生了一个压力差，能够将苹果吸出数百英尺远，并轻轻地存放在储藏箱里。因此，他们拥有了这样一个用于采摘苹果的有效装置，但很快他们就开始往更大的方面想了。
And in the Pacific Northwest, nothing is bigger than salmon. The Columbia was once one of the world's great salmon rivers, but today 14 dams block the fish's path home, and the Columbia salmon migration is a thing of the past. We were working in the Apple orchards in Eastern Washington right along the Columbia River. Vincent Todd could actually see two of Columbia's dams from the orchard. And we sort of looked at each other and said, well, what if you could put a salmon in the tube?
在太平洋西北地区，没有什么比鲑鱼更大了。哥伦比亚河曾是世界上最伟大的鲑鱼河流之一，但如今有14座大坝阻挡了鱼儿回家的路，哥伦比亚河的鲑鱼洄游已成为过去式。我们当时正在哥伦比亚河边的华盛顿州东部果园里工作。文斯和托德实际上从果园里就能看到哥伦比亚河的两座大坝。我们互相看了一眼，然后说，嗯，要是能把一条鲑鱼放进管子里会怎么样？
The idea seemed ridiculous at first, but they couldn't let it go. So Vincent Todd head back home to their shop. We set up a fruit tube in our shop, and it was about 25 feet long or so. And we went to the store and bought a dead salmon Small dead salmon and a couple dead trout. So they put the fish in the tube and whoosh It popped out on the other side and then we went out and bought some live
这个想法起初听起来很荒谬，但他们就是挥之不去。于是文斯和托德回到他们的车间。我们在车间里架设了一根果树软管，大约25英尺长左右。我们去商店买了一条死鲑鱼，一条小死鲑鱼和几条死鳟鱼。于是他们把鱼放进管子里，然后“嗖”的一声！它从另一端喷了出来。接着我们出去买了一些活的
Talapea to see if you know transport through our old agriculture or agriculture tube would cause any effect You know, are there gonna be any damage to the fish? Are the fish going to live? And the tube was about 20, 25 feet long also. And we put the life to Latvia and then they went flying into a tank of water and they just swam around and maybe leans had no issues. We just high-five ourselves. It was great.
罗非鱼，想看看通过我们旧的农业软管运输是否会产生任何影响，你知道的，会对鱼造成任何伤害吗？鱼能活下来吗？那根管子大约也是20、25英尺长。我们把活罗非鱼放进去，它们飞进了一个水箱里，然后就在水里游来游去，好像完全没有问题。我们互相击掌庆祝。太棒了。
So from there, they set about retrofitting their apple tube to transport fish. And a few months later, the salmon cannon was born. But okay, it's not really a cannon. They aren't being blasted out in any way, shape or form. The salmon cannon by Wush Innovations works like this. First they have to get the fish to swim into the tube. Salmon evolved to swim up river river past rapids and over waterfalls and they're attracted to flow. So the company built a false rapid in front of the tube.
从那时起，他们着手改造他们的苹果管用来运输鱼类。几个月后，鲑鱼大炮诞生了。但是，好吧，它其实不是一门大炮。它们并不是以任何形式被猛烈轰射出去的。WUSH创新公司的鲑鱼大炮是这样运作的。首先，他们必须让鱼游进管子里。鲑鱼在进化过程中形成了逆流游过急流和越过瀑布的习性，它们会被水流吸引。因此，该公司在管子前方建造了一个假急流。
In essence, a very small waterfall with, you know, sufficient flow to get the salmon to a particular place along the barrier itself. They are attracted to the flow up and over they come over this sort of first step and literally they will just be directly guided right into our tube itself. Once inside the tube a pressure differential moves the fish forward. So that fish then accelerates through the rest of that tube whether it be 50 feet or 300 feet. They're traveling somewhere between 15 and 22 feet a second.
本质上就是一个非常小的瀑布，拥有（你知道的）充足的水流，能够将鲑鱼引诱到屏障本身的特定位置。它们被水流吸引，顺着水流往上游，越过这第一级台阶，然后字面意义上直接就被引导进入我们的管子本身。一旦进入管子里，压力差就会推动鱼向前运动。因此，那条鱼就会在管子的其余部分加速，无论是50英尺还是300英尺。它们的移动速度大约在每秒15到22英尺之间。
Inside the tube, it's soft and slippery, with almost no friction. They are, in essence, a slippy slide for fish. You can see some videos where the fish are actually almost swimming. They're doing their natural swimming action through the tube itself. And when they reach the top of the dam Then they find themselves right back in the right back in the river itself so they can continue their journey on the other side of the dam with the barrier The salmon cannon is still pretty new right now It's being used on the Yushiga River in Washington state and they're trying to sell the system to fish and wildlife
管子内部柔软而光滑，几乎没有摩擦力。它们本质上就是一条供鱼滑行的滑梯。你可以看到一些视频，里面的鱼实际上几乎在游动。它们在管子本身里做出它们自然的游泳动作。当它们到达大坝顶端时，它们发现自己又回到了河里，回到了河里本身，这样它们就可以在大坝或屏障的另一侧继续它们的旅程。鲑鱼大炮现在还很新。它正在华盛顿州的吉加河上使用，他们正试图将这个系统推销给整个地区的鱼类和野生动物
Agencies throughout the region a lot of scientists who have tested the system seem excited, particularly because it seems to cause such little stress for the fish. But not everyone who cares about salmon is so gung-ho. It seems like if you need to resort to a cannon to get a fish moving through a river system, that maybe there's something more fundamental wrong with the infrastructure along the river system. This is David Montgomery, I'm a professor of Geomorphology at the University of Washington, and I'm the author of the book, The King of Fish, The Thousand Year Run of Salmon. And David's point is, look, the fish cannon may very well be able to get an adult salmon over a dam safely and cheaply. But that's just treating a
机构。许多测试过该系统的科学家似乎都很兴奋，特别是由于它似乎对鱼类造成的压力非常小。但并不是每个关心鲑鱼的人都那么热情。这似乎意味着，如果你需要诉诸一门大炮来让鱼穿过河流系统，那么这条河流系统沿岸的基础设施可能存在更根本的问题。我是大卫·蒙哥马利，我是华盛顿大学的地貌学教授，我是《鱼类之王：鲑鱼千年历程》一书的作者。大卫的观点是，听着，鱼类大炮或许确实能够安全且廉价地将成年鲑鱼送过大坝。但这只是在治疗
symptom of a deeper problem. In some cases, rivers with lots of dams aren't even really rivers anymore. Just look at the Columbia River, the one right by Vincent Todd's Apple orchard. The dams on the Columbia have turned what was once a mighty torrent into a chain of stagnant reservoirs, and that creates problems that things like fish ladders and salmon cannons can't fix. When salmon eggs hatch, the babies need to get back down the river to the ocean. The juvenile salmon on the Columbia River used to basically surf down the river. They just got out into the current, orient themselves, and the river took them to the sea.
更深层次问题的症状。在某些情况下，拥有许多大坝的河流甚至已经不再真正称得上是河流了。看看哥伦比亚河就知道了，也就是文斯和托德的果园旁边的那条河。哥伦比亚河上的大坝把曾经汹涌澎湃的急流变成了一连串停滞不前的蓄水库，这就带来了鱼梯和鲑鱼大炮无法解决的问题。当鲑鱼卵孵化后，幼鱼需要顺着河流返回海洋。哥伦比亚河上的幼鲑鱼过去基本上是顺流“冲浪”下海的。它们只是进入水流中，调整好方向，河流就会把它们带到大海。
Now, what happens if the river is no longer river, and it's just a series of lakes, they have to swim all the way down. They didn't evolve to do that. This has been a problem for a long time, one that no one's really solved yet. Some babies are making it down, but not enough. On some rivers, people have resorted
现在，如果河流不再是河流，而只是一系列湖泊，会发生什么呢？它们必须一路游下去。它们的进化并不是为了那样做的。这个问题已经存在很长时间了，至今没有人真正解决它。有些幼鱼成功游下去了，但数量还不够。在某些河流上，人们不得不诉诸
to transporting baby salmon downstream with boats and trucks. David's not trying to single out the salmon cannon. There's been a whole host of technologies that people have experimented with to help fish get around dams. But really, the underlying problem is that you've ecologically turned a mighty river into a series of lakes. The Washington State government spends millions of dollars every year on fish liners and other efforts to get fish around dams, but the numbers are still way down.
用船只和卡车将幼鲑鱼运送到下游。大卫并不是针对鲑鱼大炮。人们曾试验过各种各样的技术来帮助鱼类绕过大坝。但归根结底，根本问题在于你在生态上把一条大江大河变成了一系列湖泊。华盛顿州政府每年花费数百万美元用于鱼梯和其他旨在帮助鱼类绕过大坝的努力，但鱼类数量仍然大大下降。
Around the Puget Sound where I live, around Seattle, we're estimated to be down to about 10% of the salmon that we had historically. Throughout the region it's somewhere about like 5 or 8% and the Columbia River, I think it's down to two percent. You know, it varies river by river. Sam and Declan is complicated. It has to do with several factors such as over-efficient and habitat destruction. And I think that that's a characteristic of a lot of environmental systems.
在我居住的普吉特湾周围，也就是西雅图周围，据估计，我们的鲑鱼数量已经下降到历史水平的10%左右。整个地区的降幅大约在5%到8%左右，而在哥伦比亚河，我认为已经下降到了2%。你知道的，每条河的情况各有不同。鲑鱼数量的下降很复杂。它与过度捕捞和栖息地破坏等多个因素有关。我认为这是许多环境系统的一个特征。
They're actually more complex than we realize. And the worry is that many of these technological solutions to environmental problems only solve a piece of the problem, without dealing with the overall health of the ecosystem. You might be able to get the fish up the river, but the river itself is still broken. With that in mind, people have recently started calling on the government to remove old dams and return entire river systems to their free flowing state. The idea that you could actually take a major dam out 20 years ago was crazy talk. I mean, that was just not something that people would talk about as a serious political or social possibility.
它们实际上比我们意识到的要复杂得多。令人担忧的是，许多针对环境问题的技术解决方案只是解决了问题的一部分，而没有解决整个生态系统的健康问题。你或许能够把鱼送上河流，但河流本身仍然是破碎的。有鉴于此，人们最近开始呼吁政府拆除老旧大坝，恢复整个河流系统的自由流淌状态。20 years ago, you could actually take a major dam out. 20年前，你如果说要拆除一座大型大坝，那简直是疯了。我的意思是，那根本不是人们会作为严肃的政治或社会可能性来讨论的事情。
But now it's happening. After years of protest by indigenous people and conservation groups, dams have come down on the Sandy River in Oregon and the L.W.A. River in Washington State, and the salmon have begun to come back. We're not going to get rid of every dam dam in the country, but a lot of them are reaching the end of their structural lifetimes, and some are just not profitable anymore. And in those cases, David wants us to look at each one on a case-by-case basis and ask, well what about this damn?
但现在它正在发生。经过原住民和环保组织多年的抗议，俄勒冈州的桑迪河和华盛顿州的勒埃瓦河上的大坝已经被拆除，鲑鱼已经开始回归。我们不会拆除国内的每一座大坝，但其中许多大坝正在接近其结构寿命的终点，有些则根本不再盈利。在这些情况下，大卫希望我们逐个情况进行评估，并问问：那么这座大坝呢？
Does this one still make sense? Todd Delegant of Wush supports taking out old, unprofitable dams, but a concern for anti-dam activists is that technology is like the salmon cannon, could slow down these efforts, or even enable more dams to be built because companies can say, well don't worry about the salmon migration, people have designed solutions to that problem. And that's a worry with wildlife corridors more generally. Wildlife corridors cannot be a substitution for preservation of key habitat areas. That's Louise Mozingo again from UC Berkeley. The reconnection of fragmented landscapes should not be an excuse to destroy existing really
这座大坝现在还有意义吗？WUSH的托德·德莱甘支持拆除老旧且不盈利的大坝，但反大坝活动人士的一个担忧是，像鲑鱼大炮这样的技术可能会延缓这些努力，甚至允许建造更多的大坝，因为公司可以宣称：“哦，不用担心鲑鱼洄游，人们已经为这个问题设计了解决方案。”这也是更广泛意义上对野生动物走廊的担忧。野生动物走廊不能替代对关键栖息地区域的保护。再次引用加州大学伯克利分校的路易丝·马辛戈的话。重新连通碎片化的景观不应该成为破坏现有的真正
high quality habitats. We have too few of them and we need to preserve the ones that are functioning really well that are supporting large and diverse wildlife populations. Corridors only really make sense, she says, in places where habitats have already been fragmented. And now you can knit them back together in ways that support, if not a robust population, an adequate population for the species to survive. And in those situations where humans have already had a huge impact on the landscape,
高品质栖息地的借口。我们拥有的这类栖息地太少了，我们需要保护那些运作良好、正在支撑庞大且多样化野生动物种群的栖息地。她表示，走廊只有在栖息地已经被碎片化的地方才有真正的意义。现在你可以将它们重新编织在一起，其方式能够支持——即使不是一个强健的种群，也是一个足以让物种生存的种群。在人类已经对景观产生巨大影响的那些情况下，
design for the benefit of non-humans could be the key to keeping wildlife around. We spent most of the 20th century carving up and dividing the landscape with impassable objects made of asphalt in concrete. But if you zoom in, you can see the effort to stitch together habitats with the tiniest of threads that could make all the difference. A crab ladder here, a salamander tunnel there, and that's great. But if we're honest, we can't fix every problem we created by building something new. For a species like salmon to survive in the modern world, it's going to take a patchwork approach of addition and subtraction.
为了非人类的利益进行设计，可能是让野生动物留存下来的关键。我们在整个20世纪的大部分时间里，都在用由沥青和混凝土制成的不可逾越的物体切割和划分景观。但如果你放大镜头，你会发现人们正致力于用最细微的线索将栖息地缝合在一起，而这可能会带来巨大的改变。这里有一个螃蟹梯，那里有一条火蜥蜴隧道，这很棒。但坦白说，我们无法通过建造新事物来解决我们所产生的所有问题。对于像鲑鱼这样要在现代世界中生存的物种来说，这将需要采取增减结合的拼凑方法。
Sometimes the best thing for wildlife is for us to just do our best to stay out of the way. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, with Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan, Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstad, Avery Truffleman, Sheree Fusef, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KAL, W.S.A.F.R.N.S. Go and produced out of the offices of Arxign, an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. We're all on Twitter, Tumblr, Instagram, and Spotify, but right now you can be one of the first to see our brand new completely redesigned home on the internet that's fully responsive and achingly beautiful. It's 99pi.
有时对野生动物最好的做法，就是我们尽最大努力别去碍事。“99%隐形”本周由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德制作，合作者包括凯蒂·明格、萨姆·格林斯潘、德兰妮·霍尔、库尔特·科尔斯特ッド、艾弗里·特拉夫曼、谢里·菲塞夫以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是91.7KALW、WSAFRNS的项目，在位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽迷人的建筑与室内设计公司Arxign的办公室里制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞本节目。我们在推特、Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上都有账号，但现在你可以成为第一批看到我们在互联网上全新、完全重新设计的家园的人，它完全自适应且美观动人。网址是99pi。
Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-D you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——嘟——本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。